what's going on guys this is Rob and
it's Friday and I just got off work a
little bit ago so I thought I'd make
this video I'm actually here at I don't
know if you guys so totally empty
parking lot
big empty garage but yeah I got off work
at 11:00 so I figured you know I'd go
ahead and make a video for you guys so
first things first
of course the logo contest is over as
you guys can see I've got a new banner
and I've got a new logo and all kinds of
cool stuff it's awesome but anyway
that's done so congratulations to
Gabriel Alva for winning the whole thing
I sent his goodies off to him I was at
I've actually been keeping in contact
with him by email and letting him know
and all that kind of good stuff but but
yeah you know so thank you to everybody
who entered thank you to everybody who
chose to participate in this thing I get
that not everybody was interested in
making your like a logo and not
everybody really want to do that some of
the guys are just here to see my
explanations on Marvel Comics and that's
fun there's nothing wrong with that I
mean that's what this channel is based
off of so you know that's that's okay
but for those of you guys who did submit
an entry you know thank you I appreciate
it you know some of the guys had some
really really good ideas and and
gabriel's was the one that I enjoyed the
most so there will be future contests
there will be stuff that will be later
on down the road but you know for right
now we're explaining stuff so as you
guys know
age of Ultron is what we're talking
about on Monday and some of you guys had
it some of you guys got it right after
that in fact one person commented and
one person said that panel is from age
of Ultron like I've read that story and
that sudden etosha Romanov which it is
is actually the Tosh phenomenon um but
yeah it's it's it's it's cool but you
guys know that stuff that's cool but you
guys you guys see that video and you're
like immediately I know exactly who that
is you know and and you know that we're
gonna be doing age of Ultron so so yeah
you know it's it's it's fun it's
exciting so you just want to share that
with you guys just wanted to say hey
what's up you know you guys know the
contest and everything's done so so yeah
yeah that's that's pretty much it hey if
you guys haven't seen it yet go check
out Sal's video the new his contest that
he actually finished not too long ago on
the hold red frown you know
I am the law I make a terrible judge
dredd but people who are like I guess it
did a contest for people who had like
the best red frown and the winner got a
prize but at the very end of the video
or near the very end of the video is a
funny Easter egg you guys might enjoy so
make sure you guys over to go over to TV
a little house and check that out but
yeah so anyway I'll see you guys later
peace